لمواجهه موجات الغلاء المتلاحقه بدات ام
سحر في الاعتماد على نفسها في عمل
المخبوزات عوضا عن شرائها وبدات تبيع
الجيرانها واهل المنطقه
قبليها بعمل الحاجه دي اوزعها واطلع الشغل
الدنيا غاليه
الدقيق بعد ما كان ب 13 وصل 20 وفي ناس
بتبيعه ب 22 فعل هما الاول كنت باجيب بال
50 كيلو فمع غلو الحياه بقيت اجيب 25 بس
لما الغلاء كده في بيتنا احسن منه حاجه
نظيفه ومن حاجه بناكلها برده وبنبع منها
الشرح كله كان بيجي ياخذ منه لما الحاجه
غليت صراحه يعني ما فيش احد بيجي بكثر هذا
لم يكن تفكيره وسحر وحدها فقد انتشرت نفسه
الفكره لدى عدد من السيدات اللاتي اصبح
شغلهن الشاغل البحث عن السلع الارخص ثمن
واتباعه اساليب اقتصاديه في الطهور وتقليل
الكميات وتوفير النفقات بدلا من شراء
الاطعمه الجاهزه على سبيل المثال الطاقه
بحاول اجرب البيتزا المخبوزات يعني حاجات
المخبوزات اللي في الافران باحاول اعملها
انا ببقى اقلل الامكانيات تقام الان معارض
دول للسلع الغذائيه في جميع المحافظات
المصريه لبيع السلع بالتنسيق مع الشركات
والغرف التجاريه باقل من اثمانها في
الاسواق او في الوقت نفسه كثفت اجهزه
الدوله من الرقابه على الاسواق وطرحت
كميات الممثله التي تباع على بطاقات
التموين باسعار ثابته منذ فتره طويله وهو
ما يرحب به التجار لان انت دلوقت لما يكون
عندك السكر مع 10 جنيه ونصف وساب السعر
وبيكافل 65 مليون مواطن
فالسعر الحر همم لو علي شويه ما بقاش في
تكالب عليه يعني ف- التوازن ده اهم حاجه
الحكومه عاملاه التوازن واهم حاجه السلعه
موجوده بينزل من الوزاره
من الشركه الشركات التابعه نفسها علشان
همم
مخالفات او تجاوزات بتحصل في موضوع ارتفاع
الاسعار يؤثر على جميع الفئات بشكل او
باخر وبين ما ياخذ الامر شكلا ساخرا على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تزداد مشاهدات
الفيديوهات الخاصه باعداد الاكلات بطريقه
اقتصاديه بينما تدعو ام سحر الا يتجه جميع
زبائنها للخبز في المنازل حتى تجد من تبيع
له هذا الخبز الشهي تامر نصره العربيه
القاهره